[Applause]
what's up everyone my name is Jesse and
welcome to my channel I got this common
problem that many Dodge Charger owners
go through a faulty key fob if you're
having trouble unlocking or push
starting your car it might just be a
dead battery but don't worry I got you
covered to access the battery locate the
small clip on the back of the key file
slide it to the left and pull out the
key
then use the key to gently pry openen
the fob or use a flathead
screwdriver inside you'll see the
battery remove
it in this case it's a CR 2032 battery
you can easily find this at your local
auto part store if your key F5 case is
worned out or damaged you can find
replacements online just transfer the
circuit board and Battery to the new
case and
reassemble use a small fly head
screwdriver to carefully work the
circuit board out of the key fob I found
it helpful to cut the top post to let
the board slide
out for
make sure the new battery is properly
seated with the positive side facing
downward then snap the key fob back
together and just like that you got
yourself a brand new working key fob if
y'all found this video helpful hit the
Thumbs Up Button thanks for watching and
I'll see y'all in the next one late
[Applause]